hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara justice' and today I
wouldn't saw the greatly anticipated
glass this is gonna shock and surprise
you but I actually saw unbreakable when
it came out and growing up I had a great
time we split and I was really looking
forward to this movie I feel like they
they did a good job hyping it up and the
trailers looked really cool and I'm on
the em night train guys I know that lady
in the water and the happening and He
Who Shall Not Be Named the last
airbender those were not those were not
good movies but I really like all of the
others that he's done I really like him
I'm such an M night defender I think it
takes guts to tell continuously tell
your own stories and to make some really
good really good movies and some
stinkers and then just to keep going
this I think is gonna be a very
polarizing reaction review video because
I loved glass and I say it's gonna be
polarizing because as of right now it
has a 36 percent on Rotten Tomatoes for
the critics and a 67 percent for
audience I do not understand that at all
I went in with high hopes but keeping my
expectations low and I mean the first oh
my god the first like you know 10
minutes of the movie are unbelievable
the sound design the shots just the
reintroduction of our characters and
it's so good I think though without
spoiling anything that a lot of people
are gonna have an issue with the end I
was on Rotten Tomatoes
I know Rotten Tomatoes isn't like the
be-all end-all of everything but people
listen to it
the biggest complaint that critics had
was that the ends didn't feel final
enough or felt cheap or it felt like a
stupid em night twist no wait it wasn't
earned and I I don't know I think I need
to have a conversation with someone
face-to-face about it because I do not
feel that way at all
I was crying at the end I cried at the
end of glass an M night movie again I
don't know how to say his name Shambala
Shyamalan which one is it guys help
samuel l.jackson character takes a long
time to really come out of his shell if
you will he's heavily sedated in the
hospital that he's staying in and that's
in the trailer so I don't think about
the spoiler sorry if it is um he
definitely sedated so for most of the
movie you really don't get him and then
once he comes out it's really fun Bruce
Willis as David Dunn is great I okay
okay here's the thing I wish he would
have been in it a little bit more I know
that he had his movie and unbreakable
and I you know samuel l.jackson was also
there and a big part of that too and
then split was James McAvoy but I don't
know date a Bruce Willis wasn't super
super in the movie and when he was I
really enjoyed it
I do wish he would have been in it a
little bit more but to get to just the
masterpiece of it James the cowboy
McAvoy it's spelled McAvoy but everyone
says McAvoy names help he puts on the
performance of the lifetime I got the
sense from the trailers that maybe he
might have one or maybe two really big
scenes where he switches back and forth
a bunch cuz in the trailer you see that
that light mechanism that changes him so
that if he gets to the Beast and they
can quickly change him back and I was
surprised to see that it comes out a lot
more than I finish
thought it would and every time is just
better than the last if you don't even
like M night Shyamalan Shyamalan M night
if you don't even like his movies if you
didn't even like well if you didn't like
split you probably won't like it but if
you didn't if you haven't you split or
unbreakable you don't care about glass
at all just go to enjoy and admire
James's performance because oh my god
it's so good he's what triggered me
crying in the end and then it just kind
of snowballed from there and I will say
that the the guy who plays Bruce Willis
his son is so good and he's the same son
from unbreakable right pretty sure and
he's so good and they have such a good
connection I think the character
building in this was excellent I think
for a movie like nineteen years right in
the making does a good job with coddling
the audience members who maybe didn't
see the first or didn't see the second
or haven't seen them in like years and
years and years and then it also did a
really good job of not like repeating
itself too much for the audience members
who are on board for these movies and
are stoked just to see to see glass
after all these years they touched upon
things again that you needed to know but
in a way that didn't annoy me in a way
that I was like oh yeah I did actually
forget about that so thank you for
bringing that back out I think
storytelling wise it's just excellent
I'm not good at calling things and like
when the village came out I was like the
only person in the world who didn't call
the twist of the village and I loved
that movie I still loved the village
fight me I don't care don't fight me I
know it's not good but I loved it this
if you say that you're gonna guess the
twist you just you're lying to me and I
don't believe you and I never will and
that was another thing on Rotten
Tomatoes that people critics were saying
that they didn't enjoy the twist or
didn't feel weighted it not for good or
just like a throwaway I just have to
disagree wholeheartedly I thought it was
so good I couldn't believe it was
unfolding before me and now to think
back on it sure totally it seemed simple
it's a good like bringing together of
stories but damn I loved it they spent a
lot of time in the psych ward and the
mental institution and I don't think
that that bothered me at all I think it
was well paced I don't like long movies
so Tamara's never seen for this week was
speed it's an hour and a half and I
still thought that was too long even
though it's amazing but glass is over
two hours long and I think that it was
all pretty good I don't know that I
would cut anything out I enjoyed all of
it I really enjoyed our three main
characters and then we've got three like
side characters to each one of them
I really enjoyed also the doctor Sarah
Paulson I think that this movie is such
a feat in making a comic book superhero
movie it's not about a comic book
superhero it's not a Marvel film at all
it's definitely not one of the you know
superhero films that we've been seeing
but it is a movie about comic book
characters and comic books and the
integration of comic books in the story
and the the cinematography is are so
good and so well done and Knight cameo
that we all knew was coming was really
great it felt nice and felt like he was
trying to say something specific it felt
good let your dad take a walk Jesus I
think any kind of plot hole that I
thought was bothering me was explained
in the end Sarah Paulsen's characters
the doctor is like you all have Grands
delusions that you are superheroes and
so I'm trying to convince you that
you're not like well clearly they are
superheroes okay you've seen what they
do how why is this the plot that that
they're not super gay they of course
they're superheroes and then it's
explained away and you're like oh oh I
see I see there's a great line in the
movie and it says conic books are an
obsession have you ever been to a comic
book convention I laughed so hard but
again it took itself very seriously when
I say I laughed I laughed at things
because they were so serious and it
needed that for the story but there were
a few laughs nothing at all that was
trying to get a laugh though in a way
that there wasn't any like a goofy
character like it was all very serious
and it works so well I wrote that M
night twist is fire didn't think I'd cry
and the glass movie but here we are and
then on the end I wrote that is how you
correctly use social media in a movie I
think I've said this before on this show
also in Tamara's never seen that I have
a hard time really getting into movies
that use social media as a part of a
storytelling device I don't know why I
know we're in such an age of it and it
should just feel very natural to watch
but it cheapens it for me it feels dated
already because I just get the feeling
that it will be dated and I don't know I
don't enjoy it
I loved this I really really enjoyed the
ending I loved the openness of it I was
searching to see if there was an end
credits scene and he said no once the
story's done it's done I'm not really
planning on continuing this story with a
huge caveat that I probably will and I
might and I probably will so gear up for
that no I love that I love these are his
stories this is all him and I don't know
it bums me out that it's not getting
great reviews and it bums me out that he
might see that not continued on because
I love it and if it doesn't continue on
I think it got the ending that it needed
and deserved and I think that's gonna be
pretty polarizing I don't think many
people are gonna agree with me but I'm
so pumped on this movie right now I am
gonna have to go rewatch it see it for
the acting alone because it's just out
of this world James McAvoy you Queen I
just hope that a couple nominations come
out of this movie for them it was just
overall a really strong movie and
whether you like the ending or not I
think leading up to it was so strong
that's sure if you don't like it it
might soil the rest of it but I don't
know I think it's it's just so killer
thank you for watching I will see you
all next week about
oh my bones my classmates